[Musique]
pour asseoir les enfants on ne nous
arrête de gesticuler de la sorte mais je
me réchauffe patron vous ne trouvez pas
qu'il fait fraîcheur un de ces jours tu
fera basculer notre nuage
je descends chez mes amis ils ont le
chauffage eux
pas propre à pompe
[Musique]
autre
bon chez vous ne fait pas beau vie quand
il joue de la guitare ceux qui jouent
bien il est doué ce petit il devrait
faire le conservatoire
savoir qu'est-ce que se bouge et bien ce
sont des tarots
non ce sont des cartes pour dire la
bonne aventure
la bonne a vaincu 6 kw et bien on compte
les cartes et en regardant les images
qui sont dessus on raconte des histoires
qui peuvent arriver ou qui n'arrive
jamais seule nounours
mais je ne sais pas moi ah si ma soeur
emilie ac est là elle est une championne
au tarot
ma chère ça moi j'essaie tout et vous
raconte qu'un chien oui 1 2 3 je vois la
nuit 1 2 3 1 homme 1 2 3 qui apporte une
la
m 1 2 3 du mois c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle on enlève à dos 3 ça t'arrange
voyage 1 2 3 pour des enfants
sarko va bientôt rendre à la maison moi
je serais content de retrouver ma maison
un de toi une surprise surprise la nuit
1 2 3 dans la maison 1 2 3 des enfants
un deux trois qui vont dormir
tout est bien qui finit bien
on a compris ni nous nous bonne nuit mon
petit cornichons et merci pour les
prédictions bonne nuit mes enfants
oh je t'oublie y est bonne nuit
juilletà au revoir
chartaa à bientôt faire ami
[Musique]
à
te voilà nounours je t'attendais au le
l'autre non un télégramme ailleurs la
mauvaise nouvelle aux ce sont les
parents de nicolas et de pimprenelle qui
attendent leurs enfants soient tombe
très bien car ils ont très envie de
revoir leurs parents nous les ramènerons
demain oui en route bonne nuit de boer
[Musique]